who here is fascinated by life under the
sea fantastic
now what did we just do let's dissect
this for a second the simple action of
an individual raising a hand led many
others to do the same now it's true that
when individuals in a social network
have common priorities it's often
beneficial to copy one another think
back to grade school interesting that
the cool kids made you cool but copying
behavior is also common in wild animals
for example some birds copy the alarm
calls of other birds to spread
information about approaching predators
but could copying behavior in wild
animals
affect entire ecosystems that we humans
depend on I was led to this question
while studying coral reefs which support
millions of people through fisheries and
tourism here in Africa and around the
world but coral reefs depend on fish
that perform a critical job by eating
algae because if left unchecked these
algae can kill coral and take over
entire coral reefs a costly change that
is difficult or impossible to reverse so
to understand how fish may prevent this
I spy on them while they're eating algae
which can be difficult for them to do in
open parts of the reef exposed to
predators some of which on rare occasion
appear to realize I'm watching them
so clearly clearly for reef fish dining
out can be scary but I wanted to
understand how these fish do their job
in risky situations so my colleagues and
I put massive video camera stands in a
coral reef to remotely monitor entire
feeding grounds that produce a lot of
algae but are exposed to predators and
this perspective from above shows us the
feeding behavior and precise movements
of many different fish shown here with
coloured dots and by analyzing thousands
of fish movements to and from feeding
grounds we discovered a pattern these
fish despite being from different
species and not swimming in schools were
copying one another such that one fish
entering these dangerous feeding grounds
could lead many others to do the same
and fish stayed for longer and ate more
algae when they were surrounded by more
feeding fish now this could be happening
because even simple movements by
individual fish can inadvertently
communicate vital information for
example if even one fish sees a predator
and flees this can alert many others to
danger and a fish safely entering
feeding grounds can show others that the
coast is clear so it turns out that even
when these fish are different species
they are connected within social
networks which can provide information
on when it's safe to eat and our
analyses indicate that fish simply
copying other fish in their social
network could account for over 60% of
the algae eaten by the fish community
and thus could be critical to the flow
of energy and resources through coral
reef ecosystems but these findings also
suggest that overfishing a common
problem in coral reefs not only removes
fish but it could break up the social
network of remaining fish which may hide
more and eat less algae because they're
missing critical information and this
would make coral reefs more vulnerable
than we currently predict so remarkably
social networks allow the actions of one
to spread to many and could affect
entire coral reefs which feed millions
of us and support the global economy for
all of us
now our discovery points us toward
better ways to sustainably manage coral
reefs but it also shows us we humans are
not just affected by the actions of
other humans but we could be affected by
the actions of individual fish on a
distant coral reef through their simple
copying behavior thank you
[Applause]
[Music]